[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum uh i we've gotten
thomas so many episodes i think we've
done like 210 or 220 ryan good to see
you to look it up
uh if you want to sure i'll look it up
uh i hope you guys had a good week or
having a good week if not um there's
always tomorrow uh i i just had an
energy healer come to the house
and work on me and
you know some of my friends were really
skeptical like energy healer dude really
come on
then some people were like hey it really
helped me and uh
you know i feel like it uh it did give
me a little energy and
calmness and at the same time you know i
i don't know yet he says in the days to
come i'll notice more but i gave it a
chance i'm trying different things i
think that's the good part about you
know when you're when you have anxiety
or depression or whatever you've got to
sometimes try things out not everything
works sometimes it works
worse than you're feeling if it makes
you feel bad and
you know i know that therapy helps me
and i know that you know um
[Music]
exercise helps
so hopefully you're having a better week
ryan
uh
number 230 was last week 230 i mean that
might include bonuses but according to
the podcast app
i don't know this week was 2 30. oh man
i can't believe i've done this many
episodes i want to thank all of you guys
for listening 230 episodes thanks i mean
without you without patron and my
patrons who follow the podcast and
support the podcast they will get their
names shouted out at the end of every
episode of course i couldn't do it we
couldn't do it i couldn't uh could
afford to do it but um
thank you for supporting the podcast go
to patreon.com inside of you if you want
to join i'll send you a message also the
inside of you online store tons of fun
merch and autographed lexma scripts and
new inside you glasses and mugs and
tumblers
and uh the sunspin album is coming i
know i've been saying it but go to
sunspin.com
and follow us at sunspin band on the
socials
and uh that album is coming out soon
we've worked so hard on it i hope you
guys all get the album and enjoy it
because i i'm really proud of it
it's something rob danson my my buddy
my bandmate we we did it and uh i'm
really proud we had some amazing
musicians that we hired and it was
fantastic
if you're just listening to the show the
handles are ryan at inside of you pod on
twitter inside of you podcast on
instagram and facebook please subscribe
write a review it helps the show
tremendously
also um i mentioned this
in the talk fill in a soon to be aired
talk fail episode it won't be airing now
but
my grandfather wrote a diary that my my
father found after he died
a journal if you will
and it just says a little excerpt of
like
my my grandson michael is uh you know
doing a show smallville they're in the
sixth season he's a small success
and that i took it like a small success
he was being he was he was probably
being because he is a cheeky guy he was
a cheeky guy i loved him but he was a
smart ass
he was a smart ass i love that guy uh
the guest today
is will wheaton i'm so glad he came over
to the house and boy did he pour out his
guts
on that couch where you're sitting right
now right right here he really did full
of will-wheaton guts he talks about his
career he talks about life he talks
about his new book which is awesome
uh i think you're really gonna love this
episode i know you're gonna love this
episode because we get into it all
this is one of my favorites um let's get
inside of will wheaton
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
i uh i make sure that that that uh that
i always look slightly less
awesome than the guests
it's important it's important it's hard
to do when you look as awesome as i do
all the time i mean you just really have
to lower you lower it down a bit just
like geek down geek up or geek down uh
you know i try to find a nice neutral
place that lets people really be their
best selves right that's good i do too i
always like my best guests look better
and they do whether i like it or not
do you understand that's just the latest
i appreciate i want to i want to say
thanks to seth green
for hooking you and i up yeah for real
is it you and i are you and me uh it
would be you and hooking me up with you
would be you and me she and me hooking
you and me up yeah
but then i ended on a preposition
is yeah well i think but up is one of
those weird english words that can also
be a verb
that's can it be used as a verb you lift
it up he went lift lift is the verb and
then up is the direction it went so i
guess up is maybe it's not maybe is is
up a direct object is it a
you're talking to someone who did not
excel in school it's been an extremely
long time you're talking to a
professional writer who doesn't know all
the rules of english grammar so
yeah you maybe we just gently close that
door and walk on down the hallway and
act like like
door closed
how many books you've written two books
um
i've i've mainstream published two books
i've written and indie published like
four or five more maybe um and then
probably like another you know whatever
like half a dozen or so kind of like
little
one off
saddle stitched chap book things just
like short stories and little
collections and junk that i would uh uh
sell over the years
if we're going to get into this still
just a geek this book
um i just was sent it so i haven't been
able to read it but i've talked to some
people who have read it oh that's cool
they said you could either read it or
rosenbomb with your add you could listen
to it you do the voice for the audio
book i did yeah wow you do a lot of
audio stuff too i do we can get into
that that's ridiculous but
you know the thing is my friend christy
kristy kambers hello christy hi christy
she says
you talk so raw and honestly
about the past
but it's more than that it's like you
take responsibility for your actions
with whatever those actions might be and
it's just you go deeper and it's just i
can't wait to read it because
there's similarities that i see or at
least parallels that i want to get into
that you know
i think i would have jumped off a bridge
if i were your age with the success you
had because of my immaturity
and i didn't blossom till until years
later in fact i'm still blossoming as am
i and we're both going to be 50 in july
i turn 50
one month from today i one month from
today you will be 50 years old how does
that feel
i was thinking about it last night when
i couldn't sleep
and um it just feels kind of weird
um i do not necessarily emotionally feel
the way that i expected i would feel as
i was turning 50. um i feel like way
more of a kid than like i thought oh i
would be like 50 is you're like an adult
when we were 15 16 younger or even older
even when we were in our 20s
someone who is 50 ancient ancient my
grandmother visited us in indiana and
evansville in 1980 and i believe she was
like 54 years old and i thought she was
just ancient yeah and i'm going to be
50. yeah and the thing is like it's
actually really great
why i love it why
because i have so a lot of it came with
writing this book and a lot of it has to
do with like i quit drinking alcohol six
years ago almost seven years ago and
like the clarity that that gave me and
the like um
uh the focus that it allowed me to put
on myself to heal a very traumatic
childhood um and and invest time and
effort into caring for myself and
and finding like all the places where i
hurt and starting to figure out why
so as i'm like turning 50
i'm not worried about like what other
people think i
accepted and and and and have worked on
living in the reality that um
my dad never loved me and my mom made me
a thing she could use to get attention
and i eventually after years of trying
to have
a healthy loving familial relationship
with with my family of origin i had to
end it because it was so unbelievably
painful so at this time in my life where
i thought like well i mean it's over you
know it's the middle everything's done
you're boring you don't do fun stuff you
just like you go to work you come home
that's it i'm having more fun than i've
ever had in my life and honestly
like
i feel like i me instead of constantly
playing a role let me back up a little
bit and give you by the way by the way i
guess i could open up to this i i just i
feel like my whole life
i've been playing a role and i think
this podcast has given me the
opportunity to open up and be more
vulnerable and have purpose writing did
the same thing for me i've been really
trying desperately because i think i
covered up and this is a podcast about
you but it's about everybody it's about
people and i think a lot of my listeners
they're really going to be able to
relate to a lot of the things you say
but i i felt like
you know whether it was it was a reality
to me but i feel like i felt like i
didn't fit in
when i grew up i was growing up and i
felt like the only way to fit in was to
be
outlandish funny michael ridiculous
michael
trying to make everybody laugh because i
didn't feel comfortable being me nerd me
little me totally me me who didn't
mature me he was the smallest kid in my
high school yeah so i feel like i
covered something up something changed
when i was a little boy i don't remember
how old i was but it was almost like
that me i covered up for so many years
and now i'm starting to take off layers
of that and try to find who i really am
as a human being and i've what i've read
and what i've heard and what you've
already said in just a few words
um
you can probably tell me a lot about
that
so my um
i want to i'm interested about this
because we're both nerds
who who were kids who loved nerd stuff
yeah and i've had this conversation with
seth too we're nerds who love nerd stuff
and now we're adults
and each of us was part of something
that's a big deal to our nerd culture
right like each of us like has managed
to do something that is going to matter
to future generations of nerds right
right yeah is is it so like for me
that's super cool super cool real real
weird and like impossible to wrap my
head around i never thought no one would
ever think that little
rosenbaum little me would ever amount to
anything period the end that's just the
reality and nor did i i really thought
yeah i always had this death wish that i
thought i was going to die young i
thought i wasn't just i wasn't going to
make it to high school i thought i was i
just i remember thinking these things
i can't i can't fit in i can't i'm not
smart enough i'm not good enough i can't
and i don't know how it happened but
then jump to now
looking back it's like dude you did all
these things and it's it's learning how
to
sort of go hey
you accomplished this you did this be
proud of yourself and it's all these
things but it's certainly still a little
disbelief yeah and it's hard to accept
that but go on
so
i was seven years old and my mother was
um a kind of like moderately
successful commercial actor had like had
booked a few commercial jobs not a lot
but in the late 70s if you booked a
national network television commercial
you could buy a house so she did
and we did
and then she wasn't working very much
and
took me with her to an audition
where she was like to be the mom and
took me to play the role of the kid i
didn't want to do this none of this was
my idea and that is extremely important
and how old are you i'm seven seven she
takes me
we book the job
i'm seven i'm just doing what i'm told
to do none of this is like i want to do
this okay are you terrified i'm just i
don't remember i just remember like i'm
doing what mom says to do right um
and uh that we did the commercial and uh
i had fun it was you know i enjoyed it
and she said okay so now
you're going to go to the agency
you're going to have a meeting with the
children's agent and you're going to
tell her i want to do what mommy does
and she's going to have you do and she
walked me through
this is how you get an agent and you
remember that and i remember that and
i'm seven and i'm like okay i'm doing
what you'd want me to do i still don't
understand this is never presented to me
like you have a choice do you want to do
this it was this is what you're gonna do
and this is in california you grew up in
bourbon i grew up in burbank
yeah we actually lived in sunland which
is kind of like up in the north valley
which then was to los angeles what like
valencia is to la now it was like the
frontier of the north valley right
um
uh uh shortly after that the agent
signed me i was i was extremely good one
of the reasons i excelled at being a
child actor is i'm very very good at
taking direction and i was very much a
people pleaser um
the environment in my home was extremely
abusive and really unhealthy
my father was is the most emotionally
abusive person i've ever known in my
entire life wow uh i didn't have a dad i
had a bully that i had to live with
um and he loves and worships and adores
my brother and my sister anything for
them
from my earliest memory
nothing i could ever do was good enough
for him
i was never like nothing i am at one
point i was one of the most famous
actors on the planet and it wasn't
enough for him to love me
which is a really important thing for me
to figure out as i get older because it
helps me understand that
it was never about me it was just about
whatever his problem is you know
inside of you is brought to you by bambi
what a great
company this is you know how do you run
a business
without having bambi well i'm going to
tell you
you know when you have your own business
your employees can create all sorts of
interesting situations uh like getting
complaints because someone on the team
always smells horrible
you better talk to bambi somebody isn't
showing up when they're supposed to hey
you better talk to bambi um you know
where this is going with bambi get
access to your own dedicated hr manager
starting at just 99
a month
they're available by phone email and
real-time chat so onboarding and
terminations run smoothly team members
reach peak performance and your business
stays compliant with changing hr
regulations and with bambi's hr
autopilot you'll automate important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback and bambi's dedicated hr
managers are right there at a touch of a
button and you know they're they're
us-based uh they're dedicated to your
business they're there to work
for you with you giving you access to
the hr expertise and personal touch
that we all need hr managers can easily
cost 80 grand a year but bambi starts at
99 per month you know ryan i i think
people think they could handle hr issues
human resources issues
and the thing is they're so complicated
and there's rules and restrictions and
all these things that you nobody knows
about you can get yourself into a lot of
trouble and with bambi they're a great
company that makes it simple it makes it
easy they do a lot of the work for you
most of the work for you how do i handle
an employee that doesn't show up to work
how do i improve company culture
employee engagement what policies should
my employees sign how often should i
give my employees feedback these are
questions and many more questions that
you will have that you can resort to
bambi
exactly bambi
schedule your free conversation today to
see how much bambi can take off your
plate go to bambi.com right now and type
in inside of you under podcast when you
sign up it'll really help the show
spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com
bambi.com
type in inside of you now a word from
our sponsor better help
better help i don't know what we do with
that better help uh you know i
have been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is i hyper
focus on all these negative things ryan
that keeps spiraling and i can't i can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and
gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and i
know it's not i shouldn't be thinking
all these things and i it's like in my
mind i can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem-solving
mode
and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and i know
that therapy
helps that
talking to someone and having them talk
to you objectively about what works
trained professionals
helps
it just does i
doing it on my own isn't working it's
just not working
if i don't have someone to talk to i
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out
that's how i feel
do you feel that way yeah
um
you have to talk to somebody
you know
people always say well how'd you get
into therapy
it's because i just couldn't solve these
problems on my own
i couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up
until it becomes very toxic
and our body feels it physiologically we
feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why i got into therapy
and i'll tell you a lot of times i have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am i here what am
i doing and by the end of it i'm like
thank god i'm talking to somebody my
lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists
any
time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read
to me this is the easiest read ever
because it's just something i could talk
about forever
and um look better help is is a great
place it's a it's a place to to help a
lot of people when you want to be a
better problem solver therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com slash
inside today to get 10 off your first
month that's better h e l p dot com
slash
inside
it wasn't your problem it was his
problem yeah and this is a really
important thing that all of us who
survive uh trauma and especially those
of us who are scapegoats in
dysfunctional families
we have to understand that it was never
about us
it has nothing to do with us we're
unfortunate it could have been our
brother or sister right yeah like it if
it's if it's not in a family
relationship if it's in a business or
romantic relationship it would have been
the person that was in that seat before
you or it will be the person who's in
that seat after you oh what is it never
about you why does it take so much time
to figure that out because well i mean i
know for me being in the family right i
was gaslit by my mother
my mom
about a year after within a year of her
sending me to the agency right
i'm going on auditions every single day
after school you know what la traffic is
like i'm sitting in la traffic every
single day after school i'm seven eight
years old i want to be home playing you
know i want my star wars figures i want
my he-man i want my bike like that's
what i want i want to be a kid i keep
saying to my mom please let me be a kid
please let me be a kid
and she's telling me over and over again
this is what you wanted to do i gave up
my career for you like i remember that
so clearly from being so manipulative so
manipulative and then spending my entire
childhood
stand by me star trek all the way until
i'm like in my 30s and deciding i don't
really want to do this so you've never
really loved what you've done no i mean
i enjoy being on the set i enjoy being
around other artists i love being around
other artists it is where i feel
the most at home it's where i feel the
most safe it's where i feel like i'm
around people who have the same
weird expressive
thing that i have so i love being on the
set right getting to the set sucks
traffic and travel sucks audition sucks
being on the set for 14 hours it sucks
all that [ __ ]
when you're in the last eighth of the
day and like for whatever reason they
bring you in before lunch for some
reason that you don't understand like
all of that sucks but when you're in a
scene when i'm in a scene with somebody
and
something cool happens something happens
in an improv moment that neither one of
us expected or the director's like you
know i think we're gonna try this in a
wonder and let's see if we can make it
work and you pull it off right like just
that stuff feels so good the the
overwhelming joy for me of being on star
trek as a star trek fan and walking in
to there's a place on stage nine where
you could walk in the corridor of the
enterprise at kind of the curvature of
the saucer section of the enterprise you
could walk into it between the
transporter room and engineering and you
could get in there and there's this
point in the corner where you can't see
anything else
all you can see is i'm inside the
enterprise 15 year old me 16 year old me
went there as often as i could to stay
there and pretend that it was real like
i loved that i loved all of it but
everything else
the auditioning the politicking the
inherent predatory toxic nature of so
many people who are in positions of
power in this industry i hated all of it
i you expressed this to your mother i
did over and over and over again and
there was a point in my life
i just gave in
i just gave up and it would have been it
would it would have been like stand by
me changed everything and it would have
been right after stand by me
i literally went to bed and woke up the
next morning i went to bed totally
anonymous and woke up the next morning
and the four of us were like the
stranger things kids
like it happened literally overnight
and what is that feeling like that you
recall
could you could you walk down the street
yeah i mean that eventually changed
right you know that took a little bit of
time right
i don't remember exactly when this
happened
but it was after stand by me and it was
before star trek
i went to magic mountain with some
friends right and
kind of got mobbed by teenaged girls
and i didn't like it you didn't i didn't
like it at all and how old are you
i'm
probably i'm at least 13 right maybe on
my maybe a little bit closer to 14. so
you just want to be with your friends
and enjoy it right here's the thing
about that right
i have a friend who is
a legitimate
tour the world rock star right front man
for a band
right like a groupie [ __ ] dude right
like that's just like he has had that
life
and the stories he tells are
crazy all right
when i was young and i was famous
and i can remember now the occasional
person kind of like really sort of
throwing themselves at me
i never was receptive to that because i
felt like
that person doesn't see me that person
sees the thing from tv in the movies and
i'm tired of being that thing
i don't want to be that thing i'm that
thing in my house
i'm that thing wow you felt this young
age yeah i was super aware of it i was
super aware i was aware of it when we
were doing you were uncomfortable
extremely uncomfortable and i didn't
like it and i was like you know what i i
understand now you know as an i've been
married for 25 years
and and it's great i'm like and like my
wife is my favorite person in the world
and and we were talking the other day
about how when we were younger like we
just weren't people who were kind of
like
i don't know sexually adventurous or
like you know fooling around with tons
of different people and stuff like that
and it turned out that
we both came at that from a place of
like i just want someone to see me
right
like if you could see me instead of
your idea of what you want me to be this
would be really great yeah let's fool
around it'll be fun right yeah but like
i don't want to be your thing
and that was how i felt for
so much
of of my entire childhood so when
when that was all i felt like and i felt
like the only way
i
mattered in my home i knew i didn't
matter to my dad
but i thought really was it was it with
the what did he what did he say to you
what actions would he have that made you
feel like that
it was relentless
non-stop
undercutting me humiliating me
mocking me
um uh teasing me until i
would get upset and then laughing at me
for getting upset what would he tease
you about oh i mean what wouldn't he
tease me about was it it was a
competitive thing i think it may have
been
um
i you know i tried super hard to have
honest vulnerable conversations with
both of my parents for years to
understand where this all came from in
the hopes that
maybe as as a family we could find a way
to kind of work through all of this
stuff yeah
my my parents are both narcissists
um uh
and
um
when i they're the kinds of people that
you can't confide in and you can't talk
to because
when i would try to talk about these
things with my mom right it was always
turned around and twisted and like
if i said let's say i say a hundred
um deeply meaningful emotionally
vulnerable words and two words that as
it turns out are factually incorrect it
wasn't a green sign it was a yellow sign
right all we talk about is the color of
the sign because if i don't remember the
color of the sign how do i possibly
remember everything else that was sort
of how they were right so i have to
write things down
so i wrote out this extraordinarily long
like here is my heart i'm pouring it out
to you how old are you
oh gosh this was only a few years ago
it's just like five years ago oh so you
gave them a chance oh yeah like this is
your opportunity to acknowledge the
things that you've done and maybe we
could salvage this yeah and i was like i
really want this you know like here is
my reality i feel like dad doesn't love
me and never has i feel like mom made me
a thing and i want to be your son
and i want to know how we can make that
happen and i want to know what we can do
together
to like to to so i don't have to hurt
anymore
i sent that email to both of them
it was four months before my mother
responded to me
so i sent an email that said i think my
dad doesn't love me and my mom waited
four months to reply to me my dad waited
six months to reply to me
so just that spoke volumes it told me
everything i needed to know just after
just like a couple of days i was like
you know if either one of my kids was
like i'm concerned about our
relationship you should respond i would
drop you immediately when my mom finally
replied to me it was classic her it was
this enormous list of all the things
that were just so important she didn't
have time to talk to me and what i'm
supposed to do is feel guilty that i'm
taking her away from like her horse
right but
what i'm reading is here's all the
things that are more important to me
than you
the email from my dad which i did not
read came with the following subject
line
your mother wants me to email you
oh okay cool so it's not you don't want
to you don't care about this it's not
important your mother wants me to email
you and you just threw your heart out on
the table yeah with all these things yes
and this is the response you go yeah and
what was your first feeling
i was really hurt i was angry um i felt
depressed
um i have mental illness i have
depression and anxiety and ptsd and uh
i'm really aware of all of that and like
i know how
my brain interprets things in ways that
uh
that then turn around and express
themselves uh in ways that are like sort
of hurtful to me you know so like i have
to think about like okay i understand
what's going on
and i'm not the person dad said i was so
like don't react to that invented
reality from all the gaslighting and
stuff you know know who you are and know
what's going on and it's hard because
when you a lot of the response
i know from i'm not comparing myself at
all but i know that with my parents it's
more like
um
oh stop it you're being you're being
melodramatic you're so dramatic it's all
deflecting it's all deflecting oh come
on we were
it's amazing how your parents at least
my parents
they just they think that they were just
these great parents
they they
they don't they don't accept or
acknowledge any of their
like never i'm so sorry for the way i
made you that's all you wanted to hear
for your whole life all you wanted to
hear from your mother was like i am
deeply sorry and wounded
that i made you feel like this what can
i do to fix this
your father you never have heard those
things no and i and i i i i didn't and i
never will
um and i had to just accept that and i
had to accept that it's not about me
and this is a thing that i work on i
struggle with i know a lot of trauma
survivors work on it too like it's just
not about us
and it was never about us so there's
really nothing we can do
to change this thing it's like you know
if you draw a circle you put yourself
inside the circle and you put all the
[ __ ] that that that people are putting
on you outside the circle i can only
take care of what's inside the circle
i can't deal with any of this stuff
i can't change the fact that my dad
hates himself i can't change the fact
that my dad resents me for earning money
to support the family when we were kids
like i was supporting the family when i
was like 10 11 12 years old like like
all of that resentment and and uh it's
stuff it's just like
when i talk about all of this stuff you
know it's not like does it help it's
yeah because it's sort of like
i spent my whole life
participating in a thing i knew was a
lie i knew that you wanted to be an
actor will was a lie and that's the
giant lie upon which my mother built her
entire life and and sort of held me on
it too right but it's like sand you know
and as soon as i touched the sand it all
started to fall apart and i was like i'm
not gonna do this anymore and that's why
i started writing when i initially wrote
just a geek in 2004 and that came out of
the blog that i started in 2000 i didn't
know that what i needed to do was just
tell my truth right my whole life other
people had been speaking for me when i
was a child it was always my mom she was
in charge of everything then when i was
then from after stand by me it was the
studio publicists who were like moving
me through you never had your own voice
uh never had my own voice when i was on
star trek i had my own voice on the set
my cast who have become my family were
always there they always showed up they
loved me and and nurtured me and cared
for me that was the place i was allowed
to be real but the instant i was out of
the set and it was teen magazines and
star trek conventions and publicity and
all that i had to say what was put into
my mouth by other people so around 2000
the internet's really making its way
into everybody's homes now and we
suddenly have this ability to kind of
like
speak for ourselves like all of us
online have this ability to do that and
that's why i started my blog i didn't
know it at the time i was just like i
just want to write a diary and like i
want to like be online and the websites
i like reading are people's journals and
their regular lives and like i want to
do that so i did that
got the pressure to do a book which i
felt i wasn't ready to do you weren't
ready to divulge were you not at all so
i wrote just a geek when i was like 26
or 27.
and
wow so this follow-up's 20-something
years later it's 18 and a half years
later
wow and
i am so grateful to my editor david
pomerico at moro because david
uh we submitted a manuscript my agent
and i submitted a manuscript that i had
written for a a fictional
semi-autobiographical fictional story
and um i knew
that this book needed something i didn't
know what it was i knew that it wasn't
quite complete and i was like if i can
find an editor who wants to work on this
together
this is gonna be a cool story i know it
and nobody really wanted to do that but
david was like i really liked just a
geek and i recently reread it and i've
re and i've been listening to you now
and you're such a different person
just look at it and see if you would
want to go back and annotate it and
revisit it
and like
finish
that story which was started and left
incomplete 18 years ago did you feel
like it was incomplete is that somebody
or did you hearing that from someone i
was like oh my god you're right i didn't
know that it was incomplete wow until i
sat down to do it so i sat down and i
started annotating it right right and
immediately i'm like oh my god dude you
make a stupid homophobic joke because
it's like a lazy high school joke right
and uh i had to annotate that and
immediately talk about like why that is
not okay now it wasn't okay then why
younger me thought it was taking
responsibility for why it's like really
gross and offensive right right then i
get into like oh my god i just turned
like oh i just took this this woman
who's like doing her job and i made her
a punch line because it makes me the
hero of the story and i was like that's
not okay either and it's lazy writing
it's bad writing so i annotated that
then i got to a place where i and i
don't remember specifically what it was
but i got to a place where i i read what
was in the original just a geek and i
got to the end of like that paragraph or
that chapter or whatever
and i knew
all of this was happening because i
desperately wanted my dad to notice me
and i need to talk about that and i
started writing about that
and then i started writing about um
all the other things i held back
and
i kind of revisited all of this stuff
and there's moments in that book
things that were massively consequential
at the time that they happened like you
know kind of almost getting a job that
that i had completely forgotten about
uh auditions that were like i worked so
hard to prep the auditions and then the
auditions were awful like you know you
work really hard i don't i don't know
how long it's been since you had to
audition but like do you remember you
work really hard to prep a role you feel
good about it they're like there's six
scenes you prep all of them you go in
they don't care that you're there and
you start and they go oh we're only
doing the first scene why the [ __ ] did i
prep six scenes if we're only doing the
first scene and like look man just tell
me the truth we've cast this yesterday
and we didn't want to cancel the session
you know like cool i'm here like this is
what i look like this is what i sound
like uh maybe you keep me in mind for
something else but don't put me through
this yeah right that happens a lot yep
so and i was just like i hate this
and i hate that i had to act my whole
life
like it's awesome you know like well you
just got to keep on going and i was like
no it's [ __ ] and it sucks and i hate
it and i started telling that part of
the story
and then i just
in the process of doing all of this
i was simultaneously
doing a lot of
uh therapy and a lot of academic
research into childhood trauma and how
it affects the developing childhood
brain
and i began to very clearly see
what a traumatic childhood i really had
and that it was so much worse than i
thought it was and and in these
different like in the different
the different kind of online support
areas for people who were raised by
narcissists
the thing that i started seeing was
all these other people who are not me
who are not in the entertainment
industry
uh who are of different generations than
me
well their parents said the exact same
things to them that mine said to me
you're too dramatic you're so sensitive
well that's not how i remember it well
why didn't you say anything then
uh
uh you know you're just why are you all
against me it's all of these things it's
all narcissistic deflection and all that
and um
the biggest one
the number one the most effective
manipulation tool my mother ever used on
me and it worked every single time and i
hate that it worked as effectively as it
did my mom would say there's nothing
more important than family
when i didn't want to do a thing when i
didn't want to go apologize to my dad
after he hit me
when i didn't want to like go do a piece
of crap movie because i hated the script
but like they were offering some you
know slightly overscale or whatever like
that right
whenever anything came up
we're like oh no that's not you know
that's not for me
you know like this individual doesn't
want to do that my mom would say
nothing's more important than your
family why aren't you looking out for
your family
and i learned that the
that's not unique to my mother that that
is extremely common in manipulative
narcissists they say
they tell you
this thing they are in that they are
demanding you do
is about supporting the capital f family
and they weaponize the family against
you you know my mother said
you only have one mother same thing it's
the exact same thing you won't only have
one yeah and it gets you right i mean
just like in the center of your heart
when i die
you're gonna be very sad yeah yeah i
yeah
yeah yes yeah so i can see i can
remember
i mean i still hear it the thing that
was actually really
helpful and healing and validating for
me was knowing that i'm not the only
person who has experienced that and that
these things that that that that i that
i was sort of like subjected to by these
two people
are
horribly common
which means it was never about me
and there is nothing i could have done
to make it different and what i
rather than and this is the decision i
made years ago when it was time to just
end contact with with my family of
origin
was like i can keep doing this i can
keep like
hitting this wall and hoping that this
time
you know
the bricks gonna move right or i can
just walk away
how hard is it first two questions first
is how do you know you're being raised
by narcissists
you don't know well i mean
how does one know i don't know i mean
it's just like i think when you're in
the middle of it
right there's this i talk about i've
been talking i've been using this a lot
i'm hoping that a lot of people who are
who are like maybe paying attention to
me for the very first time will hear me
talk about david foster wallace so
they're going to go read this essay it's
a beautiful essay it's called this is
water and it's this uh speech that he
gave at a uh
at a graduate at a college graduation
and he starts it out by saying there's
these two fish
cruising in an aquarium and the one fish
looks at the other fish and goes hey
how's the water and the fish goes what's
water and then david foster wallace goes
on to say all of this
is water
all of the garbage in your world is
water and then he talks about it right
wow and it's beautiful and it's really
incredible and it's just about like
learning to see and experience and be
aware of whatever the water is right so
that
you're not just like floating in it
right you're like moving through it with
purpose okay so
i grew up
in this environment where
the water was yeah you have to earn love
and affection you have to earn feeling
validated and seen in your home um so
nothing's unconditional nothing's
unconditional at all
um and uh
i just really
i got so used to that
that i didn't
i could not
wrap my head around
this isn't normal
this isn't how everybody is treated
because we all want to believe that our
families love us and cherish us and are
a safe place for us and when we're told
over and over and over again nothing's
more important than family and the thing
that my mother did was she would point
at people doing exactly what she was
doing and say i'm not doing that look at
how unhappy that kid is
like you know like i'm not a stage mom
like that kid stage mom is
it wasn't until like maybe three years
ago
i saw a movie
with a with a kid in it who was
one of my contemporaries when we were
kid actors and this kid
if i said his name every single person
uh of my age group who was going on
auditions would be like oh my god that
poor kid
and that kid's awful [ __ ] mother like
we all know this kid there are if
they're if our mutuals are listening to
this they're like they know exactly who
they know you're talking right i saw him
in a movie
and i had a flashback
like um
all of time compressed
and i was not sitting on the couch in my
game room watching this this kid in a
movie
i was
a little boy
in the auditions
just hundreds of auditions where this
kid is every single time
and i can see
the fear and the sadness and the pain in
everything about him
wow
i i remember his mother smacking him
physically slapping him in the hallway
outside auditions
and screaming at him that he wasn't
whatever you know he just wasn't enough
one way or another and my mom always
making a really big deal about how like
well i'm not like that right
isn't that something you could have it
worse yeah you could have it worse you
have a house a roof over your head yeah
you don't eat every night it makes you
feel like oh my gosh i'm i'm i'm acting
like an [ __ ] so i in the midst of
this movie
i suddenly realized that there's
just no difference between me and this
kid when we're little kids on auditions
the only difference is
my mom is on a is on better behavior in
public
my mom doesn't hit me but my dad does my
dad hits me all the time
but like my mom doesn't you know
she is
protecting her like investment i guess
you know she's like making sure that
this making herself look good in front
of the people that's the outside world
yeah like
one of her defining characteristics is
like what will the neighbors think you
know like it doesn't matter what the
truth is what do they think yeah so i
had this i had this flashback that was
it was terrible and i spent a few days
in like a massive massive crisis because
of it and when i came through it
and got through the other side
it was like i had
i had admitted to myself and i had
confronted this thing that was really
painful and and had been like looming
over me my entire life which was that
huge lie and that was when i realized
and it became and it really crystallized
inside of me
that
i was never wrong
i was never
i was i was it was never my fault i was
no different than that kid
like he didn't want to be there i didn't
want to be there our mothers were making
us be there
the only difference is that
he
like his path took him into like you
know b movies and my path took me to
some place different
but
like as far as it goes as it relates to
our to our moms there was no difference
there
and i had been told my entire life
you're not that kid i'm not that kid's
mom and it was like my brain or like
this physical manifestation of like uh
like you know higher will spirit from
another dimension yeah just grabbed me
and was like dude look
look and know
and like see this
and it was real hard and it was really
painful and it was really traumatizing
from really watching and seeing this
formula
had your peer yeah and all these things
came to you all of it it was like
and i had never had like an actual
flashback before you know like i felt
like i was six seven eight years old
sitting on the couch at like you cry
so much i went into the house
and my wife was like what's wrong and i
just
crawled onto her and sobbed oh my god um
and she's like what what's what's going
on and i talked to her through it she's
been wonderful like from day one real
supportive really sees me and and uh and
and has always like just been
supportive of like the true things that
happened to me and then like also
pointing out you know like yeah i
remember you know your mom said this and
your dad did that you know like when the
kids were younger and we were like
trying to like
bring my parents into our family and
have like you know a multi-generational
family yeah um you know i absolutely
commend you and
you know this book
the honesty that i can tell comes
through it
and
the thing that i keep thinking about is
like how brave the hardest thing i have
to imagine is making that decision to
finally
cut your parents out of your life that
had to be the toughest decision out of
all the decisions and how did you do so
um
because i'm sure there's a lot of people
that you know have thought about that
have this this
these demons and these these parents
that they're like are just toxic and
they don't know what to do because
they're just it's a cyclical thing they
go through
i think that it was mostly um
it was
that choice was facilitated
by by my arrival at acceptance
of of the two people who are my parents
but they're also human beings in this
world and they were human beings in this
world before they were my parents
my
paternal grandmother was a monster
just a john birch racist
um a horrible despicable person
so cruel to my sister my mom and me
worshipped my brother worshiped my dad
that never protected us from her
my dad didn't become who he is in a
vacuum
he became who he is because of what he
experienced
he wasn't able or willing to do the same
kind of work that i
needed to do to be the dad my kids
deserve he wasn't able or willing to do
that work to be the dad that i deserve
you needed to break the cycle you were i
had to break the generational cycle yeah
my maternal
grandparents
i don't know very much about uh my mom's
an unreliable narrator and she very much
substitutes the world she wants to tell
the story about for what actually
happened
and there's just not a lot of family
alive on her side of the family that i'm
close to that i can even reach out to to
find out like what the truth is right
but the way she tells it my maternal
grandfather was an alcoholic
and
my maternal grandmother who died when i
was very young but who i remember as
someone who loved and adored and
cherished me and made me feel safe and
cared for and like all of that right my
mom presents her as this woman who was
unsupportive of her so it was very
important to mom that she was really
supportive of me and you know my dream
to be an actor
the reality is my mom wanted to be a
model wanted to be an actor couldn't
pull it off and blamed her mom for not
being supportive right rather than you
know and then like just it was always
somebody somebody else's kind of thing
understanding all of those things that
these people were not created in a
vacuum and that when i worked real hard
to like kind of be the adult in the
relationship and say could we please
work on this they they chose to behave
the way that they chose to behave
that's not going to change ever
and there came this
that when i reached this this this point
where i was like i got to heal this on
my own they're not going to be part of
it with me
it sucked
it's hard
like not having parents sucks
to this day when cool things happen to
me when this book made the new york
times bestseller list
my instinct was
oh i should i call my parents
oh wait i don't have parents to call
so i called my star trek guest
so it's your family that's my family
that's who you call yeah and they're you
know it's
have your parents reached out to you
have have they've not even reached out
to you or are they are they are they so
hurt and damaged from what you know
you've said in the press or the or the
book or that they've just they've just
shut you out as well
um i blocked their contacts in my cell
phone
uh
which is pointless to do with my dad
because before i stopped before i ended
contact with him he had not called me or
texted me or made an effort to
communicate with me for four years i
looked in my phone
four years four years
he did call me once because he
misinterpreted a thing i wrote on
facebook and decided it was about him
and called me to yell at me about it
and i was like that's you're you've like
none of this is i'm you know i don't
know what you're talking about and then
he was like it was weird it was like i
want you it's like you imagine like a
dog losing its [ __ ] at the door and then
you open the door and there's no one
there and the dog goes oh and then just
leaves right that was my dad's attitude
and i said i got to tell you when i saw
your name on my phone i was really
excited because
you haven't called me in such a long
time i would love it if you would just
call me and my dad says well you know
the phone works both ways
so like okay
when people tell you who they are
believe them
wow
you've done everything you can do you've
sent the emails i did absolutely
everything everything and you know that
right yeah yeah yeah and then i had to
um
i had to block them because
my mom would just text me
[ __ ]
and and then a whole other part of this
in the dysfunctional family dynamic is
my brother the golden child uh like got
angry at me years and years ago because
i wouldn't it was a thing with with me
like not giving them money and like he
got really angry at me and was like
you're dead to me and i my brother had
stopped talking to me years before i
stopped talking to my parents so i
haven't talked to my brother for like
it's going to be about 10 years or
something like that
um
and uh in in like in in all in all of
that
and that whole thing my mom
was constantly texting me
you know like
trying to make it my responsibility to
repair a relationship with my brother
who told me i don't want a relationship
with you right and i finally like
up on like even after i had said i'm
gonna go and heal these things on my own
she was still doing it and i was like
i'm a i don't need this
invasion of my life over and over and
over again so i had to block both of
them
how many years has it been since you
haven't talked to your parents
five or six i guess
no contact none
i did an interview with access hollywood
for
uh just as part of this whole thing you
know the promotion and all that stuff
and they were talking to like
a couple of us that
were uh child performers who have since
gone on to do something different with
our lives um we've found our own form of
success our own form of happiness our
own form of uh
uh um like fulfillment in the world
right and like what's our story so i sat
with access hollywood and i told the
story and i
you know my story is that my dad was
emotionally and physically abusive my
story is that my mom forced me to do a
thing that i didn't want to do and then
gaslighted me about it for my entire
life and like i'm sorry that they don't
like that story
a real good way
to not have me tell that story
is to have written it differently
their way right
so
access hollywood after i did this
interview access hollywood said i uh we
need you know we're a journalist
organization we need to give them an
opportunity to comment and i said okay
my dad's gonna say no comment because he
doesn't care
and my mom is gonna say i had no idea
um and i'm shocked and i said go ahead
but that's what's gonna happen and then
they're both and then she's gonna he
won't say anything and she's gonna lie
and lie and lie and lie and it is
exactly what happened
i like almost down to the words that i
predicted i was like i just know these
people and i know what they're gonna do
and i know what they're going to say and
the thing is
it's not unique to me it is common
among narcissists and it is common
among emotionally immature parents all
of this stuff to go on
taken as a whole
i'm left with
how much it sucks to not have parents
you know
it hurts there's a black hole in my life
there is a giant black hole in my heart
that will never be filled ever
i have good close loving friends in my
life who have assembled themselves
into the same shape as the puzzle piece
that is missing from me and they can go
in there and they can fill in that that
shape
but they can't fill the hole
the hole is always going to be there
because my
dad chose to not love me and i will
never know for my entire life what an
unconditional father's love is because
it was deliberately withheld from me
that sucks and it hurts all the time
having
my parents
is more painful for me
than having no parents
wow
and that really sucks it's really sad
and the part of me who's like
compassionate and empathetic and
the part of me who's the writer the
storyteller the the actor who has to
understand characters and motivations
and all of that stuff
i'm also sad for what they're missing
out on
yeah you know
it's so easy it seems like it would be
so easy i guess not for them
not for these particular people
to if you know again if you meant that
much to them to reach out and say this
needs to stop i do love you you are my
son i am wrong but it's not worth it to
them obviously yeah and that's that's
what hurts probably the most yeah yeah
um
uh it's
it sucks
it sucks
it super sucks and it's a super giant
bummer and
like
you know
i spent a lot of time feeling really sad
about that yeah and there are days where
it
kind of punches me in the back of the
head or if you see a movie and with
parents and or it happens right i mean
can you deal with like you know not to
be
sound macabre
but like you know there's gonna be a
time that comes when you know you're
gonna you'll your parents will have gone
away they'll have passed away and i you
know that happens for everybody yeah and
it's got to be like you know
it's probably going to still hurt
because there's all these unresolved
things but like you have to know
i'm look i'm not a therapist but i've
been through a lot of therapy and i've
been through a lot that we could talk
about when it comes to parents and i've
gone through stages where i'm like
crying and emotional and then realize
i forgive them and i'm like what
how did you just say that it just comes
out of you and you're like i forgive
them for you know they they did the best
they could they did i give you know my i
give them too much credit perhaps but i
also
have let things go and sort of said hey
this is the relationship i'm going to
have this is the but it almost
not almost it seems impossible to have
any kind of relationship with the people
that you're talking about yeah because
they don't want to have a relationship
that's exactly the right they want mom
wants to own a thing
i've said that my mom loves me the way
like a nine-year-old girl loves her
dolls
she loves them so much
she cherishes them she takes really good
care of them
like is constantly setting them up and
having them play out scenes and and like
living out what her dreams and fantasies
are and like she's projecting everything
that she can't get herself into these
dolls
and and like she loves the dollhouse and
just wants like the best dollhouse that
she can put them in and
that is all i ever was to her
and i think it's all that she was ever
capable of
of expressing because there's stuff
within herself that's unresolved
that she never addressed that she never
took care of
and i don't know what that stuff is
and you know you've talked about
forgiveness and
um
uh like letting go and and and going
forward and all that and
um
i
cannot
forgive the cruelty and the gaslighting
and the theft of my childhood
but i absolutely
do not need to live in like live there
anymore and move past it like i'm
talking about it a lot now right i have
talked about this more in the last two
months than i have in the last 10 years
uh it's just part of this whole process
right yeah um
i have worked really hard
to not let this be the thing that like
is constantly buzzing around my head
like i've described my anxiety as a
little swarm of bees that's kind of
always around my head right and
sometimes they're really loud and
they're really swarming and other times
they're like super cool and relaxed yeah
yeah but they're always there
they're always there and they're always
ready to swarm and go bananas like
that's just part of you know the way my
brain takes care of itself
um
uh like all of this stuff is just it's
gonna be part of me no matter what and i
have to think about like what am i gonna
do and how am i going to move forward
with all of this i don't forgive it
because it's unforgivable
like it's in the book i don't want to
talk about it because it's really
upsetting and re-traumatizing but it's
in the book
they participated in my sister and me
being abused on the set of a movie they
allowed it to happen
they did not take us off the set they
did not protect us
they failed in the number one
responsibility that parents have for
children which is to protect them and
keep them safe
and they didn't they
sold me
to
this production company
uh and and then just kind of threw my
sister in all also like because they
wanted the money and my mom wanted a
trip
right
it's
it's unforgivable stuff it's just it's
terrible inexcusable things
traumatic moments that like for decades
i was like i really need to talk about
this thing that happened on the set of
this movie because it was super
upsetting to me and the way that mom
would reply to it was well that was
really hard for all of us
oh okay i'm sure it was really hard for
you as a woman in her 30s and an adult
who's not being forced to work three
units at the same time when they're 13
um and and they're being like
regularly abused by by like the director
of the movie um uh
i'm sure it was really hard on you it
all be it all becomes about her it
always goes back to them all of it and i
write about this too there's a thing in
the book where i directly address her
and i say like listen i really want to
believe so much that part of you is
saying
oh my god
i gotta
i just hadn't thought about it this way
or like not capable or like yes that
that is or i'm sorry or whatever but the
reality is the woman i knew for 46 years
is just so heavily invested in her
victim narrative
that's always a victim always a victim
and and that and that in their version
of the story i'm just angry
and like
yeah part of me is angry and it's super
justified he's super super justified
it's really okay you know um yeah i hear
i hear you as this
little boy yeah that's just crying for
someone to just [ __ ]
listen to them yeah to con someone to
confide in yeah someone to just be loved
by unconditionally and it's been
something you've been searching for your
entire life and at least now you have a
family yeah and you have that yeah
because that's all you've ever wanted
and it was not reciprocated yeah
and that is devastating
and you have to
i mean you have to be proud of yourself
for taking these steps even though it
seems look
you
you wrote this book i mean this is
therapeutic this is yeah i think you you
write because
it helps get things out that's why we do
a lot of that that's why we write and
and i think that's
that you have to be proud of yourself
are you not
i don't spend
i'm not
i don't spend time i'm not proud of
myself i'm grateful
that i have had the opportunity
to express these parts of myself
and i'm grateful that i have
had the support to tell my truth and i
am grateful for all the wonderful good
things in my life that i have worked
really hard for
like i've done this and my wife and i
did all of this together we worked so
hard we were just um she and i took a
little tiny little uh a
couple of day little vacation um uh
i guess it was earlier this month
and
we were like
in a fancy place and it was really
beautiful and really quiet and peaceful
and wonderful and we were out for a walk
and i said you know i just want to take
a minute and
and honor and be grateful to like
35 year old us
that
we
decided
that our marriage and our family and our
partnership was worth whatever it takes
and that we
faced ever we faced down everything
together
and that we never gave up and that we
really kept working
and with my wife's support and the like
the guidance
and the understanding and the
professionalism of my agents and my
manager we were able to like go okay
well what do you want to do with your
life like who do you want to be what do
you want to do and it's like i want to
be a storyteller i really want to do
that i want to like
i want to be the person in the world who
was never there for me
right i want to be
a person who for whatever reason is like
inspiring and helpful and dependable and
reliable and supportive and inspiring
like i want to be the person i need in
the world
and we got there
and we're there right now and this is
beautiful and incredible and like
in the midst of the world being just
absolutely on fire and things being
terrible right now
we're really
lucky and we need to not take that for
granted and i want to remember
the younger version of myself who was
ready to give up who absolutely didn't
and when either one of us was like i
don't know the other one was like no we
got this and we pulled through all of it
together
so
i don't know why like feeling proud of
myself is a thing i can't do seriously i
can do it as a joke right like when i
got on super proud
when i got on the new york times
bestseller list i called every one of my
friends and i was like hey what's up how
many new york times best-selling authors
do you know add one to the list
and i was like guess what i'm gonna do
for the rest of our lives i'm signing
all your cards from your friend will new
york times best-selling author right
like it was just it's a joke they got
i've done it and my friends think it's
really funny
it's a bit awesome that's your way of
being proud yeah but but but really
honestly right
um pro feeling proud to me feels like
i'm up on a precipice and like i might
get knocked off of it right but feeling
grateful puts me in a place that feels
more like i am comfortably in like a
really safe uh like i'm not on a
precipice i'm like in a really beautiful
lush verdant valley right and you have
you have a little relief yeah you know
there's got to be some relief of all
this this is the therapy this is the
um what do you do for your anxiety what
do you do but you should obviously go to
therapy yeah
but what else helps you
i take medication
uh so i take antidepressants every
morning and that helps my brain regulate
its
chemical curiosity and um
uh i specifically do not talk about the
the the meds i take exactly
someone else's but afterwards i want you
to tell me
okay i'll tell you yeah we can talk
about it for sure um
uh and uh i have found
tremendous relief
from uh like uh cannabis therapy here in
california um just like
uh cbd and cbn uh
chemically in my brain they take that
hive of bees
and it just and it's like b smoke which
is funny joke right like it just sort of
like goes around them and it like
settles them down
and uh uh
it breaks my cycle of catastrophizing
like that's the thing that i use
that's the thing that i used to do all
the time like i would go from huh we're
out of milk too and the house is gonna
burn down like i mean like everything is
such a big deal everything i tell you
that ryan all the time like why is
everything a big deal yeah why it's not
yeah it doesn't need to be like this at
all
so everything is yes
um also from for me
keeping things inside and not work not
talking about not writing them down
whether i'm talking them into a recorder
for myself in the future just to have or
if i'm writing it in a journal so it's
not like living present in my head or
whatever not letting it sit inside of me
like like really helps and then i've
also had to learn
that like
i want to say 9 out of 10 times but like
10 out of 10 times that my anxiety is
like everything's the worst thing in the
world and like the plane's gonna crash
like right
every single time it's like that
it literally only exists in my head
i know it's not out in the world you
know like i was so right when i was i
was just traveling and i was so stressed
about it and i just kept saying to
myself dude you're invisible nobody even
knows you're here how many people have
you paid close attention to since you
walked into the airport zero guess what
nobody's paying attention to you stop
being so anxious about [ __ ]
like don't worry about stuff it's really
i really think that everyone's so aware
of us well and that is also a thing that
happens in our business because i know
like it hasn't been this way for me for
a really really really long time right
and i'm sure it was like i don't know if
it's still this way for you but i know
that it was this way for you at least
recently
there are places that we go and people
are like holy [ __ ]
i see you on tv and they get excited you
know and that's just part of our lives
right i actually really like that it
makes me feel really good because i know
when when i like somebody's work and i
just want to say oh man thank you for
that record or thank you for that tv
show it just
i loved it you know and that person if
that person is like go away i'm
massively bummed out and said like oh
man so
i make an effort to be the person i want
to encounter right so i like want to
reciprocate and honor and like really
like you know give that back a little
bit that's great but it also means
that
when like when i was on the big bang
theory and my episodes would air i would
have to be kind of hyper vigilant for
about seven days because i really have
to be aware of people like clocking me
and like you know just sort of like
aware of someone going you know you go
into a place you're like oh that guy
just made me like he's not saying
anything but he knows like like we who
live in genre television like that
that's just what we do right because
because nerds watch genre television and
the thing that nerds do that we love
like and i include myself in this group
right is like
we just know everything about what we're
doing you know we know all the actors we
know all the characters we love it so
when we see somebody from a show that we
like
you know it's like ah like i know
it's and i don't ever want to let
somebody down ever ever ever yeah that's
the worst thing
one time in my life
i had a really bad flight a terrible
transatlantic flight
landed i was exhausted i was in the one
of the worst mental places i've been in
a really really long time this is like
25 years ago 26 years ago and this group
of girls
was like hey we want to take it with yay
we love you we're here for a thing you
want to take a picture and i was like i
cannot do that and anne who was my
girlfriend at the time was like listen i
know you're having a bad day but those
girls don't know that and this is their
only encounter with you
like
do you want to do
do you want to leave them like that and
i was like i absolutely don't
and i went up to and i went over to the
girl who had approached me and i said
listen um uh i i apologize
um
uh i told her what you know i was like i
just had a terrible flight but yeah
let's do this and and and uh and i'm
sorry for for just sort of like
forgetting for a moment
and this girl you know the teenage girls
like didn't really know what to do with
that was just sort of like okay let's
take the picture yeah yeah i'd be
interested to know because it was so
long ago like she's an adult woman now
right you know
does she remember and if she remembers
like
what was her reaction then wow
this this is uh this is called [ __ ]
talking with will wheaton this is rapid
fire okay this is these are for my top
tier patrons i love you uh thanks for
supporting the podcast go to patreon.com
inside of you if you want to become a
patron i'll message you uh raj what do
you consider the key to maintaining a
happy and lasting relationship with your
significant other
respect
mutual respect
uh open honest and clear communication
stephae what's your favorite memory of
being on star trek
you you mentioned it earlier walking in
that little place where you could see
the the whole ship right i uh
god you know the thing is like there's
so many there are so many incredible
memories
i'm trying to pick one that's really
cool
that that will that will that you're
paid that your patreon will be like yay
i'm glad that they chose that one
stage
nine the stage where the where the
corridor is right it's where the
transporter room is and it's where the
engine room is right
more than once
teenage me walked in there walked into
the transporter room
pretended to be
beamed into the enterprise
walked down the corridor
to engineering
and turned on the engine
it's just neon lights
right
on a timer so like they they they strobe
you know but i knew where the switch was
and i was like yes i will activate the
engines for the enterprise and i did
that
so
so from from one point of view teenager
walks down the wall walks through the
set and turns on the lights okay that's
great
that's not what that was for me
that was for the little boy who
at
five years old
listened to star trek records
in the on the little fisher price record
player because i wanted star trek all
the time i wanted i just i wanted
nothing but science fiction when i was a
little boy that's all i wanted
um uh yeah like i was super primed for
star wars when star wars happened
because i was already in the like i was
already way into science fiction but
like
when i did that and i turned that on
i was a person making the engine of the
enterprise start
i love that and that was pretty that and
that was pretty great i love that uh
nico really quickly my two boys were
fortunate enough to create and publish a
comic just like you what did you enjoy
about the process i really enjoyed
collaborating with artists um uh when uh
when i write a comic book script and i'm
writing one right now um i will
uh when i'm talking about like setting
the scene and doing visual references
and things like that i always tell the i
try to communicate to the artist in the
dir in the stage direction you know and
i and i have these conversations with
them ahead of time this is a
collaborative process you have your
ideas i'm not directing a thing that
you're like making happen right we're
doing this together so i think
this place looks like this i think this
creature kind of looks like this but
like what do you think right and each
time
those artists have been
uh just like they've blown me away i got
to work with jamie mckelvey when i wrote
uh when felicia day and i wrote the fox
comic uh for for for the the run in the
guild and jamie is a friend who i've
known forever
um but like i was able to give him some
direction and he brought this thing to
life in a way i was just like
the comic nerds are like wow you got
jamie mckelvie from phonogram to do that
for real
like that's a really big deal right
and then like on the uh we had two
covers done emma rios did one cover uh
and paul duffield did the other cover
and i got to just give emma rios and
paul duffield artists who i just
i stand them right i was like i would
kind of like it if this it looked like
this and it looked like that and then
they both like took my idea and made it
like
even better and like made it their
version of it
i absolutely love
it's really fun i have the thing that i
have always enjoyed the place that you
know i talk about how like i never
wanted to be an actor
i don't like
i know people who are actors and artists
who just like boy they cannot wait to
get up on that stage you know they can
not wait to like get into the material
like it is it's their thing i have a
friend my friend a friend of mine right
now is about to start doing grease and
she's so excited that she's playing
rizzo in greece you know what i'm
watching the pictures of the table read
she loves everybody and i'm seeing her
she's like crazy about it and loves it
right
if i were there i would love the
camaraderie being in a cast the
relationship before when when we're when
we're lucky enough to land in a cast
where we genuinely like each other and
we and there are no divas and we form
those really great meaningful
friendships that for us from next
generation have lasted for 30 years
right like i love that i don't
necessarily need the like being on the
set thing that like my friends who
really really want to this right do it
right i get that when i'm writing when
i'm storytelling when i'm hosting ready
room for cbs like i get it in all of
those different places so like
it is the camaraderie
and that the artistry the all of us kind
of working together to generally row an
enormous enormous ship that none of us
could move by ourselves but if all of us
row in the same direction we can move it
a little bit that's cool i love that uh
the book is still just a geek uh it's
the follow-up to just a geek will
wheaton i uh this is the book it's
amazing should i read the book or should
i
the audio i would strongly encourage you
with you narrating i i would encourage
you to grab the audio yeah if you've
enjoyed this conversation i've i've
loved it
then i believe you will enjoy
that there will be some familiarity in
the audio version of it i can't wait to
it just feels like i'm going to learn so
much i've learned so much from having i
hope one day you'll come back i would
love that and listen to that fantastic
no pressure no expectations i'm curious
to know what you
get out of it when you're done with it
if you wanted to i i'm just curious i
could tell if it's anything like this
conversation i'm gonna just love it
because this is just it hits home in a
lot of ways that you you wouldn't know
because i haven't expressed but there
were so many times where you you were
speaking where i was just going wow and
another thing is i was looking at ryan
who was like going wow because he didn't
have this kind of childhood he had
unconditional love oh dude that's the
best so coming from someone who's had it
he's just like it's so it's so foreign
to you right
and it's tragic it's tragic but it's
also
wonderful that you're here and you're so
open and forthcoming and i just i'm glad
you came by and i i thank you for
allowing me to be inside of you today
yeah what's your handle what's your
instagram handle so it's uh i am it's
will wheaton it's will wheat it's will
wheaton um and if and if your listeners
want to find me and don't want to
remember a ton of information will
wheaton.net is my blog great everything
is their blog and they can find out
everything you're doing every tabletop
everything
this guy is full of ideas full of great
things
so what is it again the website
will wheaton.net will wheaton.net folks
and check out this book still
just a geek this has been an absolute
joy thanks for having me on the show
it's been a real privilege it's been
awesome
i mean i didn't expect him to be that
open i mean
yeah
you didn't have to do much
and that's that's always nice when the
guest is willing to come in and
and really go for it yeah it makes my
job so much easier when i don't have to
pry [ __ ] out of them and they're just
open to talking about depression
massachusetts and all and their parents
boys what a relationship he had or lack
of
with his family that makes me really sad
i mean we all have relationships with
our parents whether they're bad or good
or somewhere in the middle but his was
was south of bad
yeah it was rough it was rough
i appreciate you will for uh
being so
um
vulnerable forthcoming
um
it's nice it's good it's good to hear
it's not good to hear that it happened
to you but it's good for other people to
hear your story
and it will help them i hope
um
uh thank you guys for listening today um
it's been a really
crazy week crazy week i'm still dealing
with my anxiety
um ryan how are you doing just still
dealing with it as well yeah i'm just in
a different way yeah
you got to keep talking yeah
yeah always feel free to call me dude
yeah seriously i go through it every day
so
you know
i'm here i always
i know what it's like
i freaking know exactly what anxiety
feels like and depression i know what
they feel like
so if you ever have any issues and
you're like i need somebody who besides
better help of course
because you know they're your therapist
but if you ever want to talk to a friend
yeah about hey did you ever try this
drug or did you ever try this
medication or have you ever felt like
this just to relate sometimes that helps
well i'll take you up on that take me up
right dude yeah seriously yeah
um
thank you patrons we're going to read
the top tier patrons patreon.comcity to
support the podcast
uh i love you and become a patron and
i'll send you a message here are the
shout outs here we go
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e brian h nico p robert b
jason w sophie m kristen k not to be
confused with kristen
crook correct raj c
joshua d c j p jennifer n stacy l jamal
f janelle b kimberly e mike e eldon
supremo 99 more ramirez santiago m chad
w leanne p janine r maya p maddie s
belinda and chris h dave h gila g
brad d
ray h tabitha t tom and liliana a talia
m betsy d chat l marian dan n big stevie
w
angel m rhiannon c corey k dev nixon
michelle a jeremy c andy t gavinator
david c john b brandy d
that's a bong hit yvore camille s the
chief joey m design otg eugene and leah
hi guys nikki g cory k or no corey just
corey kdb nicole patricia heather l jake
b megan t mel s orlando c caroline d
christine s
sarah s eric h jennifer r shane r emma r
jeremy v andrew m robert g zettoichi
zatoichi 77. hello again i've screwed it
up again andreas
ann or andreas andreas
oracle chris r michael f karina n
samantha w michelle d amanda r love
crafty amanda s
gen b
and kevin e those are the top tiers
uh i thank you for listening if you
really enjoyed will wheaton you're still
listening right now tune in next week
please subscribe please uh
follow us on our handles you know them
by now uh they're right here if you
don't or just rewind to the beginning of
the show we love you uh from myself in
the hollywood hills california michael
rosenbaum all right brian is here in the
hollywood hills california
wave of the camera we love you be good
to yourselves all right
i'll see you next week
[Music]